حفلة حفلة حفلة
حروف اللغة تزهو الليلة
لنستمتع معها هيا
حفلة حفلة حفلة
حروف اللغة تزهو الليلة
لنستمتع معها هيا
دق الألف باب الباء " تك تك حفلة حفلة"
فتح التاء، تبع الثاء "تفضل، أهلا أهلا! "
نادى الجيم حرف الحاء "أين الخاء؟". قال "جاء!"
قفز الدال فوق الذال
لعب الراء ومعه الزاي
أخذ السين نقاط الشين
ضحك الصاد "ها ها ها"
حفلة حفلة حفلة
حروف اللغة تزهو الليلة
لنستمتع معها هيا
"ها قد جاء حرف الضاد" تك تك، "حفلة حفلة"
هتف الطاء، لاقى الظاء "تفضل، أهلا أهلا! "
هز العين كتف الغين "انظر للفاء يظم القاف! "
ركض الكاف وراء اللام
عجب الميم، ابتسم النون
رقص الهاء، معه الواو غنى الياء "لا لا لا!"
حفلة حفلة حفلة
حروف اللغة تزهو الليلة
لنستمتع معها هيا
حفلة حفلة حفلة
حروف اللغة تزهو الليلة
لنستمتع معها هيا